si el primer balance del ataque contra
el hospital infantil de mar y por la
localidad ubicada en el sur de ucrania
que está siendo fuertemente bombardeada
por el ejército ruso según el gobierno
ucraniano al menos tres personas entre
ellos un niño fallecieron durante este
ataque y otras 17 resultaron heridas el
presidente ucraniano blog de merche
levski ha dicho por su parte que la
televisión rusa ha mencionado este
ataque pero ha mentido según silencia al
decir que en el momento del bombardeo no
había ni niños ni mujeres dentro de la
estructura están mintiendo como siempre
hacen a dichos él es quien también ha
añadido que hará todo lo posible para
que se encuentren aquellos bienes que
los oligarcas rusos poseen en diversos
países de la unión europea bien es que
se les que quiere que se confisquen su
vida de lujo se acabó